well joining me now are my peers back
talk to you contributor esther cracker
broadcaster and journalist jenny clement
and this is very exciting the bbc's
international editor and author jeremy
bowen welcome thanks for inviting me
please really to have you here really it
adds a touch of class not the you lady
but a touch of class um
i want to start well first of all
welcome to all three of you obviously i
want to start first of all with the
queen
because we've just seen her in this
unprecedented uh situation where boris
johnson and his trust go up to balmoral
for the first time uh to do the official
process of the handover to be prime
minister and she did look okay but she
looked frank i mean the pictures she
just looked friends she's 96 years old
yeah exactly yeah
now we hear that she took a turn for the
worse she's got to spend some time now
resting she couldn't attend a privy
council meeting after doctors intervened
ongoing health issues obviously
i guess jeremy for me as you're the
nearest to her age obviously
[Laughter]
um
what do you think about all this because
it seems we've only known one monarch in
our lifetimes
yeah yeah i just feel like it's going to
be such a seismic moment when she's not
here anymore i think that the national
outpouring will might even dwarf what
happened when diana is killed i think
it's going to be absolutely huge and a
national trauma of the greatest extent
yeah you're quite right i was born in
1960 she's already been on the throne
for eight years yeah at that point it's
amazing isn't it yeah it's absolutely
amazing and
you've traveled the world where they
don't have monarchies
what do you think of the institution of
the monarchy in the modern times well i
think it's worked for britain uh i think
the queen herself
is uh a national figure like no other
you know universally respected uh even
by people who say they don't agree with
the monarchy
the
[Music]
what will happen after that i think
people might ask more questions because
of course there's you know there is
there are people who say that maybe
we've had enough of the royal family but
i think that while the queen's there
uh of course those questions are very
much on hold one of the problems esther
is we have the duke and duchess of
sussex and all that drama going on uh a
report tonight from omid scobee this
in my opinion revolting little specimen
it keeps popping up as the sussex is
middle mouthpiece and keeps trashing the
royals on their behalf tonight trashing
prince william
saying that he believes until william
admits his accountability of all the
terrible things he's done
to megan and harry they can't be
reconciled they're literally in windsor
park tonight
half a mile from each other these two
boys
and they haven't even said hello to each
other this is damaging it's not just
damaging to them and their relationship
it's damaging to charles who also hasn't
seen harry and apparently i was told on
good authority this week he feels
incredibly hurt by what's going on he's
going to be king sooner rather later
probably but this is also damaging to
the foundation of the monarchy i think
this is now the best time for the the
monarchy to transition and i think i
know no one has made this point but i do
think the queen should advocate because
i do think the country she won't do that
she won't because of her sense of duty
but i know it's actually because they
believe in the natural law of succession
they believe that once you interfere
with that i was told this by somebody
senior in the royal family that if you
start interfering with the natural
process you then let other things come
into play for example
if the queen was to abdicate and prince
charles gets killed in the car crash the
next day god forbid you have a
constitutional crisis which is why they
don't abdicate we've had one in the last
you know few hundred years but i think
that the the issue the royal family has
is how do you rebrand how do you become
more tolerable because obviously we're
seeing this feud with harry and and
william and i think it's very
unpalatable and i think it's actually a
disgrace to the queen's legacy and what
she's worked so hard to build and you
have these two freeloaders
on the other side of the world just
basically making money off her legacy
and of her years of hard work i do think
that maybe it's time okay if she won't
abdicate maybe prince charles should
step up and take
sort of more he's doing more and more
no i think the monarchy was devised at a
time when you could never imagine
someone living 96 years and the thing
about the queen is she is all about
dignity that's why she doesn't want to
be seen uh you know in a wheelchair or
with mobility aids she's a very
dignified person and i think
her having to continue until the very
end kind of goes counter to that and and
again with the the harry and megan
business you do have to think about the
question of dignity and i don't think
there is there is anybody republican or
otherwise who who would say that the
queen does not look if you
cannot have a renegade
royal family running around pouring
those titles to the highest bidders you
can't it's incredibly damaging that's
why i've been on about this for quite a
while because i could see the danger to
the actual future of the monarchy if it
looks like the royals basically don't do
any public service or duty they fly
around in private jets preaching about
the environment and then they cash in
their titles to netflix and spotify for
hundreds of millions of dollars aren't
harry and megan getting more and more
unpopularly so i agree also in america
they are they are but i think the damage
the drip drip drip damage to the
integrity of the monarchy
it should not be under having to be a
distinction between monarchy and
celebrity they're two separate things
and there isn't the queen's always
understood yes which the queen is
understood and i think maybe megan
didn't understand that when she married
into the royal family oh i think she
understood completely what she wanted
i'm very cynical about it because i
think she's this is all
an actress at the top of her game
getting what she wants out of this using
our royal family to make herself very
rich and famous i think that will only
work as long as people want to hear her
and i think i'm getting herself i think
the thing is we'd find her less
distasteful if she did it for free you
know she talks about all the things that
she wants to do she wants to charity to
work they have to sell themselves
actually give up the titles
just be megan markle and harry right and
go and do your thing and find see how
you get on yeah what i have a problem is
is they come back here to boost their
royal status to remind people that they
are royals because that's where the
money is and then they trash the
monarchy and the institution and they
trash the other oils i mean you just
can't have it always